malgré les apparences c'est archi ne
sont pas sur une partie de chasse mais
sur une compétition de tir à l'arc
leur objectif remporter les championnats
de france de tir par équipe de club
un rendez-vous qui clôture la saison
donc les archers ont un parcours à
réaliser
ils tirent sur des animaux qui peuvent
être aussi historique fantastique ou
réelle cette année le site du musée de
port royal des champs de magny les
hameaux a été retenue pour organiser la
compétition du 6 au 7 octobre
le parcours a été soigneusement préparée
pour l'événement il faut un terrain
boisé un terrain vallonné pour pouvoir
avoir des cibles montante descendante
avoirs et des variations de ne pas tirer
de situations de tirs au total 250
archers venus des quatre coins de la
france sont venus sur ce rendez-vous
chaque l'équipe était composée de trois
sportifs
là c'est le plus haut niveau parce que
la sélection se fait par rapport au
classement national de
ce que les marchés ont fait réaliser
tout le long de l'année donc c'est
vraiment les 40 premières équipes du
classement qui sont là où les 25 équipes
chez les féminines qui sont là donc on
estime généralement on retrouve des
archers qui sont dans le meilleur niveau
en individuel dans ces équipes là la
compétition a finalement été remporté
par les archers du sia c'est comme le
veut le règlement ce sera cette équipe
vainqueur d'organiser la prochaine
édition de ces championnats de france 3
d